nous avons voulu savoir pour quelles
raisons d'abord un éditeur accepte de
publier de tels documents est pourquoi
en quelque sorte qu'il se fait complice
de telle heure
écrite en prison et est publié mamie à
l'administration pénitentiaire moniteurs
qui se respecte qui compte avant tout
c'est pas la qualité de l'auteur sa
qualité du manuscrit
c'est pas qui dit c'est ce que l'on dit
en fait vous vous donnez de la promotion
un personnage assez assez sordide et
finalement vous ne déprécier pas un
petit peu le métier d'éditeur la gestion
de cette façon et le métier vous avez un
jugement moral sur un autre livre sur un
livre vous avez un jugement moral sur un
homme le l'éditeur est là pour témoigner
lorsque l'on parle du goulag lorsqu'on
parle vague d'offres hitler l'éditeur
est là pour témoigner
il n'a pas à juger c'est pas parce qu'on
publie un livre sur le goulag quand et
pour le goulag c'est pas parce que je
publie l'histoire jake mérine que
j'approuve jacques mais vous ne pourrez
pas que c'est un peu choquant de voir un
avocat devenir un peu l'imprésario
littéraire de son client
je ne suis pas la pressio littéraire de
mon client je n'ai connu une manuscrit
que lorsque l'éditeur a bien voulu me le
communiqué je ne suis pas non plus un
censeur comme l'éditeur lui même nous
n'avons pas à l'être et jacques merina
une personnalité telle qu'on ne lui
dicte pas la conduite à tenir
on n'aurait pas que les que les prisons
devienne un petit peu trop je crois des
salons littéraires aujourd'hui on a un
papillon a bien marché alors pourquoi
pas ont continué mais il est intéressant
monsieur que les prisons deviennent des
salons littéraires
c'est mieux que de devenir des
antichambres des actions meurtrières et
criminel on a beaucoup plus de chance
nous avocats de voir un individu se
réhabiliter
lorsqu'il a écrit des livres et pourquoi
l'on lorsqu'il en aura touché les droits
alors que sortent en prison il n'a rien
est bien certain que cela les aidera et
je favoriserai de toutes mes forces
cette possibilité pour les détenus de
s'exprimer curieusement c'est autour de
cette région doloise que s'articule la
carrière si l'on peut dire de ce
gangster de vocation internationale il
ya dix ans jacques mesrine qui porte
alors allègrement la trentaine et gérant
d'une petite auberge non loin de
compiègne au milieu des bois c'est alors
le début d'une longue série de méfaits
qui le mèneront
demain devant les assises de la scène
pour répondre d'une bonne quinzaine de
chefs d'inculpation du hold up à la
prise d'otages et nous y reviendrons
avec l'épisode du tribunal de compiègne
en passant par l'association de
malfaiteurs et la tentative d'homicide
nous sommes alors en 1973 l'auberge ne
lui suffit plus il part pour l'amérique
enlève un milliardaire s'évadent d'un
pénitencier tu de garde-chasse
il faut ajouter à cela une bonne dizaine
d' attaques de banque pour en arriver à
ce qui nous intéresse c'est à dire
l'évasion de compiègne arrêté au mois de
mars à boulogne billancourt
il fait immédiatement opposition à une
précédente condamnation et demande à
comparaître devant ce tribunal qui a
précisément rendu le verdict mais c'est
là qu'apparaît son caractère disons
diabolique mesrine a envisagé de longue
date qu'il pourrait être arrêté il a
déjà repéré les lieux quand il était
libre et il sait que l'on peut déposer
une arme sur le rebord de la fenêtre
il lui suffira ensuite et ce n'est
certainement pas le plus difficile de
trouver un complice
et c'est ainsi que le 6 juin 73 mesrine
demande à se rendre aux toilettes
un gardien la compagne mais quand il
revient dans son box d'accusés mesrine
cette fois est armé baissez vous tous où
je tue le juge crie-t-il c'est
l'affolement
le gars de refuse de le lâcher mesrine
l'entraînent derrière le président et
braquent le canon d'une arme sur sa
nuque dans sa fuite il va tenter de
tirer sur le substitut sur les gendarmes
ensuite il va tirer précisément puis il
s'enfuit avec le président la voiture
est poursuivi dans les rues de compiègne
il réussira toutefois à s'échapper et
courra jusqu'en septembre 1973
demain pour son procès au palais de
justice de paris
c'est une véritable forteresse que l'on
verra il aura fallu aujourd'hui six
heures au greffier de la cour d'assises
de paris pour lire l'acte d'accusation
c'est à dire la liste des faits
reprochés à jacques mesrine est à trois
complices auparavant en fin de matinée
le gangster avaient été amenés au palais
dans un fourgon sévèrement gardée il y a
d'ailleurs le service d'ordre des grands
jours autour du palais de justice
jacques mesrine reste tout de même
titulaire si l'on peut
lefebvre de deux évasions spectaculaires
lui la première le 21 ou 71 mesrine a
réussi à s'échapper d'une prison
canadienne de pénitencier
saint-vincent-de-paul un véritable une
véritable forteresse est un exploit
véritable soit permis d'ailleurs ensuite
de dénoncer à la presse là bas au canada
les conditions épouvantables détention
dans cette prison qui est d'ailleurs été
fermé en suite et la deuxième évasion
c'est en france la première du genre qui
ensuite inspiré jean charles gil ok elle
remonte au 6 juin 73 mesrine c'était
valait il pas être justice de compiègne
il avait fait caché par un complice un
revolver dans les toilettes et il s'est
enfui en prenant un juge comme otages
pour sortir du palais de justice
aujourd'hui évidemment il ne fait pas
peur il est désarmé et c'est revolver se
trouve dans la tablette envers des
pièces à conviction devant lui il les
regarde de temps à autre alors dans le
box mesrine apparaît très convenable
tout à fait comme il faut et les grands
même large gamme tête ronde avec une
moustache à un poil voyous et une tête
ronde avec les yeux qui bouge tout le
temps sur mesrine sans sa salle et
commence à entamer un dialogue un
dialogue muet avec les journalistes
devant lui par-dessus ses avocats qui
feuilletait le dossier comme si elle ne
connaissait poste assez amusant venez
qu'il manquait une femme dans le box
elle qui est apparemment sa compagne de
caves à ouidah là c'est dommage hans
steiner est sérieusement malade elle
sera jugée plus tard son cas était 10
juin représente un côté mystérieux
disons plutôt sympathique du caractère
de mesrine c'est à dire la femme celle
qu'on respecte et aussi celle contre
auxerre
pour l'instant donc il y au côté de
mesrine trois hommes deux tout à fait
broder lui et le troisième un peu plus l
écart à droite c'est le troisième qui a
permis l'arrestation de mesrine et donc
il ya un certain contentieux entre les
deux hommes alors mesrine va être jugé
par cinq hommes et quatre femmes dont
l'une tout à fait à droite et comme un
petit chat qui regarde un gros chien un
cruel et ce sont ces jurés qui vont
décider si mr il va réussir ou non à
faire son procès spectacle bien le
feuilleton mesrine commence nous
retrouvons régulièrement peut le faire
c'est une affaire très grave une bavure
des mesures administratives seront à
prendre
ainsi s'est exprimé le garde des sceaux
alain peyrefitte en apprenant l'évasion
de jacques mesrine et de françois bès de
la prison de la santé à paris
en effet s'il ya quelque chose qu'on a
du mal à comprendre tout de même c'est
cette évasion en plein jour entre 10h et
10h30 ce matin de l'homme que l'on
considère comme un des plus dangereux
criminels auquel la police et eu à faire
ces dernières années et de deux de ses
complices
le plus jeune
reeves qui n'était pas comme les deux
autres spécialistes de l'évasion a été
tué sur le fait du mur de la santé
mesrine et baisse ont pu s'enfuir en
arrêtant une voiture mais ce qu'il ya de
plus ahurissant dans cette histoire
c'est que ces trois hommes garder dans
le quartier de haute surveillance de la
santé ont pu s'échapper parce qu'il
disposait d'un véritable arsenal caché
dans le plafond du parloir l'endroit où
il pouvait s'entretenir avec leur avocat
on a ironisé en france souvenez vous au
moment de la sphère bader et de ses
complices sur les armes qu'on trouvait
chaque jour la prison de stuttgart et
bien la prison de la santé n'avait rien
à envier aujourd'hui à celle de star
game toujours est il que jacques mesrine
est en liberté oui mesrine fils
d'industriel architecte diplômé décoré
en algérie mais dont toute la carrière
s'est effectuée dans la délinquance
d'abord puis dans la violence armée
le procès de celui qu'on a appelé un peu
hâtivement peut-être l'ennemi public
numéro 1 a eu lieu l'an dernier 20 ans
de réclusion criminelle
mais il devait être jugé à nouveau
bientôt pour des crimes dont il s'était
rendu coupable au québec
il a publié un livre écrit dans sa
cellule et où il a vu où il avoue 39
meurtre et c'est ce que disent ceux qui
comptent bien en lisant ce livre et on
ne sait pas s'il est plus truand que me
tall un mythomane finalement en tout cas
il a adressé un certain nombre de
menaces de mort également depuis sa
cellule et le danger qu'il représente en
est peut-être plus dans le personnage
qu'il s'est fabriqué que dans celui
qu'il était réellement revenons d'abord
sur les circonstances de l'évasion de ce
matin avec maurice olivari pour bien
comprendre ce qui va suivre
deux mots d'abord sur le décor les trois
hommes qui s'apprête à faire la belle
sont détenus dans le quartier de la plus
haute sécurité c'est le terme propre
l'une des 4 l de ce grand éventail où
l'on répartit les prisonniers en
fonction de leur caractère plus ou moins
dangereux
chaque quartier comporte une aile de
détention où sont rassemblés les
cellules de part et d'autre un couloir
lequel couloir débouche sur des cours de
promenade
chaque prisonnier de ce quartier étant
isolé même pendant la promenade à 9h50
donc ce matin deux hommes tournent en
rond chacun dans sa petite cour
mesrine et baisse 9h55 mesrine est
appelée au parloir parloir réservé aux
avocats
au bout de quelques minutes mesrine
prétend vouloir montrer à son avocate
maître giletti que leur conversation est
enregistrée que des micros sont
effectivement caché dans le faux plafond
mesrine monte alors sur la table ouvre
ce qui n'était en fait qu'une cache et
en sort cinq revolver dans ce trou sont
enfouis outre les armes des bombes
lacrymogènes de protection des fusées de
détresse et une corde marine de 12 m
pendant ce temps la baisse demande à
rentrer de promenade il rejoint mesrine
et ensemble les deux hommes pénètrent
dans le prétoire
ici à droite où sont enfermés en
permanence un surveillant et deux sous
directeur
les gardiens sont aussitôt maîtrisé
dépouillés de leur uniforme et de leurs
papiers est enfermé dans une cellule
celle du troisième larron rives
il ne reste plus qu'à retourner dans
l'une des cours de promenade à franchir
un premier mur avant d'utiliser des
échelles providentiel laisser la part
des ouvriers en train de renforcer
comble d'ironie les fenêtres de la
prison entre temps l'alerté a été donnée
l'un des gardiens de la paix en faction
dans la rue aperçoit les fugitifs tirs
sur yves qu'il tue sur le coup mesrine
et baisse ont le temps d'arrêter une
voiture et de disparaître sans laisser
pour l'instant du moins de traces
le reste de l'actualité c'est d'abord la
suite de l'évasion de jacques mesrine
hier matin l'homme qui avait écrit dans
son livre on ne s'évade pas de la santé
et pourtant ce soir encore dans la
nature il est donc bien fallu qu'il
dispose d'importants de complicité et
c'est tout cela que l'enquêté c'est
d'établir en ce moment enquête centrée
autour du témoignage de m giletti l'une
de ses avocates
dernière personne à l'avoir vu quelques
minutes avant son évasion
la prolongation de la garde à vue de m
jid et ya d'ailleurs été obtenu du
parquet par les policiers on s'attendait
34 heures de cavale ce soir pour jacques
mesrine et françois bès depuis leur
évasion de la santé hier matin par ce
mur d'enceinte de 15 mètres de hauteur à
l'angle de la rue jean dolent et de la
rue de la santé depuis la chasse au gros
gibier se poursuit pour les hommes du
quai des orfèvres bar fréquenté par la
pègre à paris en banlieue hôtel louche
repères de crues ans aucune trace des
deux fugitifs
les anti gang et les enquêteurs de la
brigade de répression du banditisme sont
pour l'instant bredouilles ils ont passé
aujourd'hui au crible la voiture de la
fuite
1h20 retrouvait boulevard lefebvre
les perquisitions effectuées à montreuil
au domicile de christiane giletti
l'avocate de mesrine et à son cabinet du
16e arrondissement n'ont apporté aucun
élément nouveau utile à lenquête en
prolongation de garde à vue au quai des
orfèvres
christiane giletti va passer sa deuxième
nuit au dépôt et jacques mesrine lui en
liberté mais commençons par jacques
mesrine qui demeure à saisissable depuis
son évasion de la prison de la santé
après le hold-up d'avant-hier au casino
de deauville à hold up auquel on est
maintenant certain qu'il a participé les
forces de l'ordre ont bien cru pouvoir
passer jacques mérine ce dimanche dans
les bois de bernay cela sur l'indication
d'un habitant de la région à dispositif
de quadrillage du bois et est
immédiatement mise en place ce soir
pourtant jacques mesrine a une nouvelle
fois jouer la fille de l'air
officiellement on n'ose toujours pas se
prononcer sur l'identité des deux hommes
aperçus à 6 heures du matin dans le
petit bois qui jouxte la commune de
bernex
après la découverte d'un pistolet de
doux talkie walkie
on se contente d'affirmer qu'il s'agit
bien des auteurs du hold up commis à
deauville mais tout semble accuser
mérine et son complice françois besse en
tout cas ce soir malgré l'échec des
recherches de l'après midi le dispositif
de quadrillage a été maintenu pour la
nuit et de nouvelles battues ont été
entreprises dans plusieurs autres bois
de la région
les gendarmes sont maintenant convaincus
que les deux gangsters ont eu le temps
de quitter la zone où ils ont été
aperçus
avant la mise en place du quadrillage et
il étend le champ de leurs recherches
est ce que vous êtes sûrs qu'ils sont
actuellement dans une bras sur qui on
veut qu'ils fassent dans le bois étant
donné qu entre l'alertent ce matin à
6h30 et le moment où le dispositif de
bouclage était à peu près réaliser ces
camps du coup les un certain temps
disons entre 1h 2h facilement au cours
desquels il était possible d individus
de s'échapper pour retrouver les deux
hommes la gendarmerie n'avait pourtant
pas lésiné sur les moyens
deux cents hommes des hélicoptères des
chiens la brigade d'intervention armée
jusqu'aux dents
mais d'ores et déjà il semble bien que
mme erin si c'est bien lui a une
nouvelle fois réussi à jouer la fille de
l'air
ce matin on a appris en effet qu'une
moto avait été volée dans les rues de
berne et la cavale continuerait donc
mais les moyens des deux gangsters
s'amenuisent
décidément jacques mesrine le gangster
recherché par toutes les polices de
france depuis sa spectaculaire évasion
le 8 mai dernier du quartier de haute
sécurité de la prison de la santé à
paris
jacques mesrine aime faire parler de lui
il ya aujourd'hui de réaliser un hold-up
parfait sans tirer un seul coup de feu
il s'est emparé de 450 mille francs dans
une succursale de la société générale du
raincy dans le département de la seine
saint denis
il a reconnu en outre être l'auteur du
hold up du casino de deauville commis le
26 mai dernier
c'est à cette heure ce matin que mesrine
et un complice se sont présentés chez le
fondé de pouvoir de la société générale
du raincy après avoir que leur forme et
la femme et la fille de ce dernier
mesrine a laissé son complice au
domicile du fondé de pouvoir et s'est
rendu avec ce dernier à la société
générale où il s'est fait remettre les
fonds il a ensuite emprunté la voiture
de sa victime qu'il a laissée sur le
parking de la gare du nord à paris avant
de disparaître
jacques collet a rencontré pour nous la
victime de cette prise d'otages et de
soldes on m'a exposé ce qu'il voulait
c'était clair et simple notamment il
était trop lent il m'apporte la faillite
il m'a mis le marché en main donc c'est
quoi son projet son marché c'était la
bomba prise d'otage de ma famille et je
partais avec lui
beaucoup de travail e
pour rançonner enfin pour relever en
fait l'objet il exprime et s'assure
qu'elle tend tout à fait quel moment
comme à son habitude donc de faisait
partie avec la banque donc
demain d'istres sont partis d'ici et on
sait on est arrivé donc devant l'agent
snover de leur cinquième au palais de là
où on est rentrés puisque l'agent
s'était ouverte et c'est à ce moment là
donc
il m'a fait rentrer dans mon bureau en
fin d'après un scénario qu'elle est et
qui a été donc déterminé par lui et chez
apple donc nous battons et c'est là sous
la menace que nous sommes et est
descendu au coffre retirer des fonds
quelle somme je sais qu'on parle de 401
compile personnellement je ne veux pas
retourner à l'âge ans je pourrais vous
dire
le préjudice suis c'est à dire quel a
été son comportement avec votre épouse
votre fils entré autres et doria très
correct d'ailleurs il m'avait dit que si
en fait
tout s'est passé normalement et
il ne saurait convaincre
y'avait pas problème avoir de son côté
si vraiment les choses se tournait bien
s'ils n'avaient pas d'anicroches
qu'est-ce que vous inspire précisément
le genre de comportement des truands
comme l'huile qui se perdent le narguer
la police devenu une chose à perdre
malheureusement
arrestation en belgique du compagnon
d'évasion de jacques mesrine françois
bès avait d'ailleurs participé à de
nombreux coups en compagnie de mesrine
après leur évasion de la santé depuis
plusieurs mois il semble que baisse
avait pris certaines distances par
rapport à l'ennemi public numéro un
c'est à issel dans la banlieue de
bruxelles que les policiers belges ont
arrêté en compagnie de trois de ses
complices
alerté par les hommes de la brigade de
répression du banditisme français les
policiers belges lui entendu une
souricière françois besse a donc été
repris toutefois rien ne laisse supposer
que cette arrestation met les enquêteurs
sur la trace de mesrine mesrine qui
reste la priorité des priorités pour les
policiers français la sphère mesrine
après son agression contre jacques
tillier et de notre confort de
l'hebdomadaire minute
mesrine a écrit hier à plusieurs de nos
confrères de la presse écrite 1 pour
résumer disons que jacques mesrine
affirme n'avoir pas voulu tuer tillier
mais avoir voulu le pu lire par ailleurs
selon certains la police estimait que
jacques tillier n'a pas donné une
version tout à fait exact disons de ce
qui s'est passé réellement lundi matin
je vais essayer de rejoindre ma place
sans trop de problème voilà c'est fait
une version tout à fait exact de ce qui
s'est passé lundi matin alors
aujourd'hui on peut quand même se poser
une question où est la vérité
et bien pour la première fois la vérité
nous allons peut-être la connaît tout au
moins une des vérités de cette affaire
car jean jacques dufour pour la première
fois jacques tillier sur son lit
d'hôpital à accepter ce matin de
répondre aux questions d'un journaliste
de télévision devant des caméras de
télévision alors j'ai rencontré tout à
l'heure dans le couloir de l'hôpital
juste avant de m'entretenir avec jacques
tillier la demoiselle balestra zee qui
est commissaire au srpj de creil
elle m'a affirmé nous n'avons jamais dit
que nous mettions en doute la version
des faits donnée par jacques tillier
donc non démenties 7 1 des ventes de ces
informations qui disait que jacqueline
n'aurait peut-être pas dit toute la
vérité ce qui revêt pas d'impacts de
balles dans la cuisse à cyril fausses
informations sensationnelles anticorps
directement ce matin dans le couloir de
l'hôpital voilà pour ce point mais
revenons-en à la lettre de mesrine ou
plus exactement au lait ou l'envoyer le
lancaster au matin de paris à l'aurore
au quotidien libération bien minutes et
amis aux substances
on peut y lire truc là je prends mon
papier parce qu'il faut que je regarde
c'est une citation trion d'honneur ça
n'existe pas mais l'honneur bafoué
ça se défend jusqu'au meurtre
jusqu'à l'absurde jusqu'à l'odieux dans
la violence le ton est donné ensuite le
gangster explique qu'il n'a pas voulu
tuer tillier mais le corriger je n'aime
pas les gens qui salissent pour le
plaisir
il accuse ensuite le journaliste de lui
avoir proposé quatre cent mille francs
pour cette interview et d'avoir voulu
lui tendre un piège
il explique aussi qu'il a enregistré à
son insu le journaliste et que celui ci
a sali c'est en tout cas le mot
qu'emploie mesrine lé commissaire
broussard et devos mesrine n'apprécie
pas ils préfèrent des adversaires comme
eux un jacques tillier à propos de cet
enregistrement jacques mesrine a dit
qu'il le communiquera ultérieurement
mesrine s'en prend aussi à
l'hebdomadaire minute et à sombre sa
direction et de conclure je n'ai pas à
être en glorifier je suis un criminel
mais je n'ai pas à être sali injustement
à dater de ce jour ce sera le tarif de
lac alors ça c'est donc la version
jacques mesrine c'est l'une des vérités
de cette affaire
l'autre vérité c'est celle que vous avez
recueilli cessa de nos amis qui nous
avons pu voir jacques tillier très
fatigué de balle n'ont pas encore été
extraite
il a pourtant accepté de répondre à nos
questions et à la lettre de jacques
mesrine lettre dans laquelle le gangster
affirme donc qu'il n'a pas voulu tuer le
journaliste 2000
écoutons donc cette interview de jacques
tillier
je pense que
il se dit très fort il est peut-être
plus fort que le médecin légiste qui
prouve le contraire comme moi je sais
bien ce qui s'est passé dans la grotte
et si mesrine voulais pas me tuer il
suffisait tout simplement que devant le
chemin en matière de balles dans les
jambes ou pour m'empêcher d'écrire une
balle dans la balle dans la main pendant
péché d'écouter une balle dans le rail
et me laisser avec mes vêtements me
regarde pas rester immobile côté
téléphoné à la gendarmerie on me
retrouver comme ça il n'y a pas de
problème là une minimum tu me laisses
dans un trois attachés avec une ceinture
enfin les pieds un pas les mains
attachés avec une ceinture avec quand
même une balle qui reste la mine ici une
île et peut-être vexé parce que ma loupé
mais c'est pas mon problème
tout ce que je sais moi je suis très
content qu'ils m'aient loubet il dit
aussi que vous avez voulu le piéger et
vous vouliez lui tendre un piège
je sais pas si je voulais le pied enfin
depuis le départ c'est quand même lui
qui m'a pied derrière il est persuadé
jacques mesrine c'est quand même un
grand garçon est elle habituée des
rendez vous secrets sais pas et je suis
pas le premier de deuxième quart des
interviews quand même ça va très bien et
serait non seulement mesrine peut le
dire mais et ça on en parlera un jour où
peut-être que les intermédiaires en
parlerons jours
tout seul jacques mesrine savait très
bien qu'il n'y avait pas de policiers
derrière que les policiers et a suivi
par les policiers
il n'y avait pas de policiers que les
policiers n'étaient pas prévenus de
cette interview que je n'était porteur
d'un baby ben je peux même vous dire
mieux jacques mesrine était tellement
confiant que il m'a fouillé uniquement
en masse on a fouillé uniquement dans la
voiture le haut mais j'aurais très bien
pu avoir si j'avais été un homme de la
police j'aimerais bien y avoir un bip
bip dans mon sac
il a jamais fouillé mon sac ou sur mes
jambes j'aurais pu avoir un pistolet je
me suis trouvé tout seul un mois il y
avait jacques mesrine devant moi dans la
grotte
parce que faut rentrer dans la grotte à
jacques mesrine
quand on est journaliste à minute
sachant les opinions politiques les
jacques mesrine
jacques mesrine était devant moi avec
son ami paul moi j'étais derrière il ya
eu uniquement un milliard de de briques
et kiki qui nous éclairait j'aurais très
bien pu avoir un pistolet à eau que j'ai
ressorti de mon de ma cuisse que les
abattre tous les deux mesrine avec
confiance en moins d'ailleurs il le dit
dans la lettre savaient très bien qu'ils
pouvaient rien se passer du tout vous
avez été policier la dst est ce que vous
pouvez penser qu'à cause de ça jacques
mesrine a pu laisser croire que vous
aviez encore des relations avec l'ancien
lyonnais
donc c'est pas ça que jacques mesrine a
voulu punir un journaliste de minute
quelques monstres inve jouent aux
brigades rouges ça c'est son problème
c'est pas lumière jacques mesrine a
voulu punir un journaliste de minute
punir un ancien flic mois peut-être
d'avoir été ancien ancien policier non
seulement j'en suis vraiment fier mais
absolument rien à rougir
en ce qui concerne l'enregistrement que
mesrine a fait la preuve c'est bien la
preuve c'est lui qui tend un piège
s'il est malade moi aussi et
l'enregistrement que mais ce qu'on a
fait je suis alors vraiment très serein
chacun sait aussi bien du côté de mon
journal
l'information policière c'est à dire les
policiers ce que j'ai dit ce que je pas
dit ce que j'aurais pu dire savez c'est
plus on m'a dit hier quelqu'un m'a
téléphoné hier pour me dire que les
gendarmes avaient fait la reconstitution
et je rien contre les gendarmes
mais comme j'en avais mis dix minutes du
fond de la grotte fameux bosquet où je
me suis caché gendarmes avaient des bons
gros deux cas si une cigarette au bec
moi j'étais à poil trop mal dans le
corps la trouille culotte reviennent ces
quatre cent mille francs questions que
vous auriez offert à jean chris rain
pour cette unique arrêt ça c'est un bon
directeur qu'il faut poser la question
s'il veut bien donner 40 millions je
prends tout de suite
pensez vous qu'ils avaient pris contact
avec mesrine c'est bien c'est lui qui
vous a joint ecoutez-moi al'inverse de
mesrine fut jamais balancé personne dans
ma vie il ya ce que mesrine appel dans
sa lettre ces faux amis
ils seront ravi de l'entendre et ça je
crois que c'est assez faux amis de
parler peut-être qu'ils parleront le
jour et vous avez réussi à retrouver
comment ça c'est mon problème mais je
l'expliqué dans minute les délires
puissant porté garant pour moi comme il
ya des gens qui sont portés garants pour
mesrine vis-à-vis de moi ces gens là ont
été trompés
ces gens là sont des voyous ces gens-là
soins code
quoi qu'on dise mesrine et peut-être que
ils seront un jour quelque chose à dire
alors
voilà monsieur bonsoir 15h15 cet après
midi porte de clignancourt à paris au
milieu de la circulation
une fusillade éclate une voiture grise
s'immobilise criblé de balles à
l'intérieur tu es net
jacques mesrine et sa compagne
grièvement blessé par les policiers de
l'office central de répression du
banditisme qui avait tendu un véritable
guet-apens à celui qui depuis plus d'un
an et demi faisait courir et narguer
toutes les polices de france avant
d'aller plus loin vous propose de
revivre les événements tels qu'ils se
sont déroulés
chronologiquement cet après midi porte
de clignancourt ici au milieu de cette
place de clignancourt jacques mary n'a
été abattu à 15h sa bm démarre on se
faufile dans la circulation
deux camionnettes de déménagement la
bloque à l'avant et à l'arrière
les rafales de mitraillettes part de
l'arrière de la première camionnette
jacques mérine s'écroule mort sur son
volant sans avoir eu le temps de découpe
lier les grenades qu'il portait sur lui
les inspecteurs se précipitent évacue de
la voiture la fiancée de merine
grièvement blessé trois quarts d'heure
après le corps de jacques mary n'est
transporté hors de la bm v nous avons
relevé dix neuf impacts de balles sur le
pare brise de la voiture
les inspecteurs qui le suivait depuis
plusieurs jours n'ont rien laissé au
hasard
oui rien n'avait été laissé au hasard ça
d'après midi tous les grands patrons de
la police était là monsieur ducret
patron de la pj de paris le commissaire
broussard de l'antigang et ils ne
cachaient pas leur satisfaction
il n'y a pas eu d'abus je vous dirai non
par la foi
les deux services j'avais des deux
services au crb et berry les 19 balles
mortelles dont celle de crpc de
répression du banditisme de la bmi brega
l'antigang les rivalités entre les deux
après midis oublier au milieu d'une
foule de policiers de journalistes et de
témoins voilà j'ai vu quelqu'un sur le
volant bien blessé je ne savais pas qui
ce qui s'est passé c'est à ce moment là
que plusieurs voitures civiles s'étant
arrêté son coin c'est cette bmw et
plusieurs jeunes en blouson que je ne
savais pas qui c'était 7 après que je me
suis rendu compte
ils avaient tous des brassards en ce
sens mis par terre parce qu'ils
croyaient peut-être que le blessé allait
avoir des réactions et ils se sont vite
levés ils ont entouré la voiture et à ce
moment là c'était plein de voitures de
police étaient plus auparavant il y
avait rien d'anormal y avait juste un
agent de la circulation la circulation
césaire le décès de l'ennemi public
numéro 1 est terminée
c'est en 1961 souvenez vous il ya
presque 20 ans que jacques mesrine
commençait sa carrière de gangsters si
je puis dire vingt années de meurtre de
cavale de hold up qui avait fait de cet
homme de 36 ans un bandit vraiment pas
comme les autres c'est en mars 1962 à 26
ans que jacques mesrine fait son entrée
dans les annales judiciaires pour un
banal cambriolage rivaux 18 mois de
prison
une fois libéré il retournera bientôt à
la délinquance avec des ambitions
décuplées hold-up pillage d'appartements
et braquages dans les banques premier
règlement de comptes
mesrine ira lui-même qu'il est devenu un
tueur sans remords et sans regret
traquée en france ils courent sa chance
au canada après une courte tentative de
retour au travail honnête et il enlève
son ancien employeur il n'arrivera pas à
toucher la rançon à cause de la
défaillance d'un complice mais le voilà
hisser parmi les grands du banditisme
international
il est pourtant arrêté deux ans plus
tard en 71 alors nouveau coup d'éclat il
réussit à s'évader de la prison de haute
sécurité de montréal avec cinq autres
détenus
puis il pousse l'audace jusqu'à attaquer
ce même pénitencier les armes à la main
pour tenter de libérer les amis qu'il
s'y était fait
c'est un échec mais après cette action
sans précédent
le cas mesrine est posé il n'est pas un
truand ordinaire septembre 72,2
garde-chasse sont tués dans la forêt
québécoise ce sont les deux seuls
meurtre officiellement attribué à misery
il rentre en france ou en mars 73 il est
arrêté on ne le gardera que trois mois
il avait préparé d'avancé les moyens de
son évasion des armes cachées au palais
de justice de compiègne lui permettent
de prendre en otage le président du
tribunal
il réussit à s'enfuir il est maintenant
l'ennemi public numéro un trois mois de
liberté seulement le 28 septembre 73 la
brigade antigang le cueille au gîte à
paris il offre le champagnes commissaire
broussard une des rares personnes qu'il
dit respecter et qu'il désigne
volontiers comme un grand flic pendant
la langue d'instruction de son procès
trois ans et demi il écrit un livre
l'instinct de mort où il revendique 39
meurtre alors même qu'il n'est pas
encore jugé gros succès de vente
la justice est bloqué les droits
d'auteur plus de 500 mille francs au
total 19 mai 1977 jacques mesrine est
condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle après un procès de quatorze
jours le voilà à la santé la prison dont
on ne s'évade pas il est placé dans un
cachet ce quartier de haute sécurité
réservé aux grands criminels réputé
dangereux oui mais pour un an seulement
le 8 mai 78 la prison de la santé perd
sa réputation
mesrine s'évade des qhs avec son ami
françois bès un troisième compagnon
d'évasion karman rive est tué sur place
au coin de la rue de la santé vous avez
la casquette et puis avec cette espèce
de blousons comme les matons pareil je
discute avec la vallée comme moi que
j'en reviens de loin le plus dangereux
comme sa place
mais sur des armes et tout un matériel
avait été cachée dans le parloir de qhs
mesrine a donc bénéficié de complicités
multiples dix jours plus tard
hold up au casino de deauville mesrine
est blessé d'une balle à l'art en juin
ils vident la caisse de la société
générale au raincy il avait d'abord pris
en otage chez lui à son domicile
le fondé de pouvoir et l'avait contraint
à l'accompagner jusqu'à la banque nous a
dit qu'il voulait fall qui nous les
voisins qui veut simplement de l'argent
mais pas d'ici ni à nous novembre 78
prise d'otage manquer chez monsieur
petit président de la cour d'assises de
paris
c'est pour protester contre l'existence
des quartiers de haute sécurité dans les
prisons où l'on transforme dit il des
hommes en faut en juin enlèvement
d'henri lelièvre l'octogénaire
milliardaire de la sarthe
mesrine le libère le 28 juillet contre
une rançon de 6 millions il a désormais
les poches pleines
un autre en profiterait pour tenter de
disparaître pas lui
le 10 septembre 79 il accepte un rendez
vous avec jacques tillier journaliste à
minute près de creil dans une carrière
désaffectée il le bleis de trois balles
il écrit aux journaux j'ai voulu punir
tillier par ses écrits par ces messages
ou ces menaces aux journaux les
interviews données
ces déclarations lors de son procès il a
veillé à construire son personnage à
nourrir sa légende
mais saura-t-on jamais leur sort secret
de cette vie errante courage sans doute
mais bâti sur le crime et en définitive
gâcher une réponse est peut-être donné
par le titre du récit qu'il en a fait
l'instinct de mort
jacques mesrine est donc mort cet
après-midi abattu par des policiers
robert werner s'est rendu à la planque
comme l'on dit de mesrine rue belliard
il rencontré ceux qui depuis quelques
jours ont croisé dans l'escalier jacques
mesrine
sans le reconnaître bien sûr
derrière cette fenêtre celle de
l'appartement de mesrine des policiers
perquisitionnent il est 20 heures
ces prises de vues a été fait dans la
cour de l'immeuble et voici la façade
donnant sur la rue mesrine se faisait
appeler tout vol tous les demeures et
rue belliard à quelques pas de la porte
de clignancourt ou internet
mais c'était un voisin comme les autres
locataires de maisons
il habitait à quelle hauteur les trois
méritage par une autre ancienne avec une
madame tout seul et quelles étaient ses
allers venues régulière le matin le soir
nom est marc giblet rarement et quand il
venait il restait pas longtemps dans
l'appartement sans sortir enfin de
sortir au rarement venu en deux fois
pour ce même si vous voulez puis nous
sommes rentrés de force de sortir des
sentiers jamais y découvrir une joue
avec la barre d'abord oui c'est la cure
ou que je n'ai qui change et qui
l'avaient jamais admis au rock
mais paul tools ne figure pas sur ce
panneau portant le nom de tous les
locataires les voisins ils ignoraient
tout de ce monsieur qui ne faisait pas
de bruit ne parler à personne il le
croisait dans l'escalier parfois le
matin en venant de refermer leur journal
relatant la sphère mesrine précisément
comment vous avez prises alors vous avez
appris que mesrine habitaient dans la
même maison
la rue belliard donne sur le métro
clignancourt dans l'appartement de
mesrine on s'est trouvé en présence d'un
dispositif anti policiers portent
matelassé pour les balles entre autres
mais ce soir on commande toujours les
faits ce à quoi un petit peu partout il
y avait des
des inspecteurs en civil qui avait des
mitraillettes par les mains les bistrots
sa cavale et ouais c'est un petit peu la
femme en général et voient ce que j'ai
vu quand j'ai vu un monsieur qui est au
volant il avait
nous sommes encore tourner la tête mais
cette année cinq ans je viens pas du
tout
et il y avait une femme qui est à côté
de lui qui est sorti de la voiture et
qui est tombé par terre à partir de ce
moment été révélée très blessée après
moi je l' ai vu blessé ici sur le côté
là il certainement à la tête basse que
ça c'est pas mal
et puis après la preuve en a pas il ya
des craintes de faillite qui sont
arrivés tous les manuels et sony est là
s'est échappé il est allé ou quand elle
est sortie de la voiture il allait
sortir il est tombé par terre
évanoui l'autre côté nom n'était pas
évaluer parce qu'ils l'ont relevé et non
assise sur une borne ici là et j'ai
conscience qu'il va nous et je crois
qu'après ses vannes
[Musique]